[Musique]
la miss a révisé le nouveau chroniqueur
à quelque chose
numéro de trapèze numéro 2 tout en
bresse et paul mara
[Musique]
bah acheter des bonbons exact c'est pas
l'évoquer nous rend si tu oublies
l'espace zoom zoom sem total seize
jeunes et ou bien mais comment voulez
vous existez à sa vie d'ado c'est génial
mais ce week end et chopin rfef a pas
dégueulasse on n'en parle pas ça en
train de bouffer la cervelle j'ai pas
mangé pas d'échec panda c'est une simple
écoute regarde oui bof
[Musique]
où il ya le truc inondations dans mon
appartement je sais pas où était le
magnifique magnifique gens soient les
actes et magnifique tu marques tu
marques qua non parce que je tiens à
préciser qu'il avait mangé du champomy
sa famille magnifique du marbre et
chocolat mais quelle angoisse mais
qu'elle le ghana seul et même des
coucous sans famille dans le nouvel
épisode tous ensemble inondations chez
delphine avec mes supers voisins les
pompiers
[Musique]
talent émission à force de tout accepter
on ne vient plus personne théo faut pas
stigmatiser la cnaf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]